is my form
when I do this we practice this drill
all right
if we do this more feel all the time we
do one two three
one Squad
you'll know that it's it's been there a
long time
so many people ask me about that what
should I say
okay whatever it keeps
like this you know what are you gonna do
right so you ask someone full of this
yeah
like all he got as far as you can
put one in there
um
all I'm doing is putting my form here
I didn't hit him
okay like you know this person is
holding me and he's doing his hands
he is hitting as hard as he can
we can do it
this is just your form now this is one
and I can control here
takes away two
now he's going number eight
how many games can you do
okay boom
go down
number nine
how many times
so I have to be able to Chapel yeah
I have to be able to attach that as much
as I can
I have to be able to
type that
as much as
that is the real reason we do what we do
twice
understandable
one control
two
redirected
three
and later you start to build all of
these things
this year
okay I hit to this shoulder is going
here
this all I'm doing
now of course I can do all of these
things from with afterwards but
I'm going to show you the one part of
doing this
and this
so what I go here I want to push that
all the way into each other so
okay so one more time
he doesn't like that so there he goes he
grabs this
he comes back and my hand is here to the
back all right four walls
all of these things that I want to do
yes all this I can also do it later but
this one was what I want to do
I bring this down and like I said
through that you know guys look where I
am
starting to get into a moments
but when I drop down
and I start to bring it down to
do one of those thoughts he's going to
stop my elbow side a little bit
okay
drop it down
so I know this is the closest
or we could go
and that turning my body and you're
catching your face
this is where I'm going there to do now
when I bring it down go stop it
and look where I am on my shirt from
here so I take it away
and then I'm back to my Shuffle again
three
four
and I'm like
but it's again the same same girl
he's not going to kill me
I had to also be you know able to do
what I need to do so that's why I have
to be able to hit this thing and it
doesn't require that
you know so he doesn't talk that's why I
am from Empire
catch that elbows okay this is for me
just practicing this touching of this
tank I want to be able to do
[Music]
yeah
and if I try to hit it then it changes
the nine
I want to be able to touch here
this is very simple this is not
be
no across at that point is then because
this is what's going to happen
that is exactly what's going to happen
but if I'm here
that's what I'm trying to do
because the three strikes
this is what's going to happen she comes
with three strikes
this is what's going to happen
okay so that means I'm learning
this is not just the second moves
but a little bit safer
they're not killing each other so
kind of the mistakes active
we can switch up late
I have final answer to Rebecca myself
and I'm still work in McDonald's
tomorrow
so I can still get french fries
I am practicing to be able to no stream
things okay so did a giant
make it slow
you know who kill yourself I'm a little
for a few more minutes
so I I want you to uh I never Supply
[Music]